le budget présenté par mon gouvernement
est un budget d'augmentation claire et
nette des moyens de nos
collectivités en
2024 grâce à l'extension du fond de
compensation de la TVA grâce à la
pérennisation du fond vert grâce à des
niveaux élevés pour les dotations de
soutien à l'investissement local nous
allons accompagner vos projets à hauteur
de 12 milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire
près d'un quart de l'investissement
local l'année dernière nous avons
augmenté la DGF pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans grâce à cela la quasi
totalité des communes ont vu leur DGF
rester stable ou progresser en
2023 cette année nous avons décidé de
continuer sur cette voie je pense aux
communes nouvelles qui conserveront le
bénéfice de leur montant de
DGF de plus le projet doit de finance
pour
2024 prévoit une nouvelle hausse de la
DGF pour les communes comme vous l'avez
demandé nous irons plus loin encore pour
vous soutenir aussi je vous annonce que
j'ai décidé d'augmenter la DGF des
communes de 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires la hausse atteindra donc
320 millions d'euros l'année prochaine
vous l'avez souhaité nous le faisons en
2024 la DGF des communes augmentera au
même rythme que
[Applaudissements]
l'inflation
pour les années à venir comme l'a
annoncé le président de la République
hier nous devons refondre la DGF au fil
du temps elle est devenue de plus en
plus complexe et de plus en plus
incompréhensible pour les communes il
faut un système juste et clair c'est la
mission du Comité des finances locales
qui devra relever ce défi dont nous
mesurons tous
l'ampleur de plus
comme vous l'aviez souhaité monsieur le
Président du Comité des finances locales
le gouvernement continuera à aider les
collectivités face au coût de l'énergie
l'amortisseur du prix de l'électricité
sera maintenu en
[Applaudissements]